what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
wall street is trying to get rich the
rest of us trying to get our
lunch money right i am here with polina
we're both
in uniform all black every day this is
black that is definitely
this is definitely black anthony that's
black
this is black this is gray no mine is a
wash black because this is an old shirt
i don't know are you are we going to
argue over what's black and what's not
black
john is this black or gray
yeah oh john's in between my little
brother's right here but he's he's
camera shy he's too good looking for the
camera
don't worry block five is not the
sponsor of lunch money go to
blockfit.com
sign up you can earn interest on your
crypto
or you can sign up for the waitlist for
the bitcoin rewards credit card where
you swipe your credit card and you get
paid back
in bitcoin go to blockby.com pomp what's
up
china central it is definitely great
come on china's central bank and the u.s
federal reserve agreed that a fully
autonomous national digital currency
is not feasible but fed chair jerome
powell believes when a digital dollar is
developed it must provide users with
more privacy
than the people's bank of china's
planned digital
you want one
i don't know what privacy they think
that they're going to do but i will give
the federal reserve chairman powell uh
kudos
yes we do need more privacy lunchtime
money wait
lunch what are we lunch money lunch
money
did you forget the name of the show yes
oh it's like kind of like well you
forgot what black looks like
this is a lunch money first time
okay it's over the moment is over keep
going it's not the first time i've
agreed with them
uh i do agree that we need more privacy
than what the
people's bank of china's digital
currency will provide but i also agree
that we probably need even more privacy
than jerome powell thinks we need
and so uh it's like he's a step in the
right direction but rather than taking a
step we need to take a whole leap
in the other direction than the chinese
digital currency so
that's great uh what i do find
interesting though is there's no longer
a debate on are we going to have a
digital
currency or not united states it is now
pretty much spoken about like
duh of course we're going to have it
just a matter of when what kind of
conversations do you think powell's
having at the moment
uh i i would not want to be him just
given the constant
stress and changes and all the stuff
that's going on all the time
all right mark cuban is investing in a
decentralized
startup called espresso with a z
two z's a decentralized finance started
building data
automation tools and it raised two
million dollars in funding for mark
cuban
arrington capital and cms holdings among
others
what does it do uh would it say data
automation tools
it probably just ingests data i don't
know i haven't looked at this but it
probably just ingests
data and then does all sorts of
manipulation uh
represents it etc so it makes a lot of
sense interesting is mark cuban now
very much into like d5 nfts crypto
oh yeah for sure he uh look
i think that mark cuban probably more
than most people i know who have had
great success he's very open-minded
but he also does the work right like if
you go back and you look at his story
uh in the early days of when he was
doing computer software like he went and
he read the manual
how many of you were willing to read the
manual to understand uh whatever the
computer was that they were building on
and like for the software
uh and so same thing here is like i have
no doubt that he's sitting he's doing a
ton of work
he's really really trying to understand
the market the opportunities and then
he's going he's deploying capital so
what
kudos to him uh michael arrington was
also in that round you didn't mention
him capital but i know he's in there i
didn't go ahead
okay more funding news some of the
biggest names in finance are betting big
on the success of greenwood the digital
banking platform introduced last year
by co-founders ryan glover and rapper
activist michael killer mike
render the fintech startup named for the
early 20th century african american
business
district in tulsa oklahoma that earned
the nickname black wall street has
raised more than
40 million dollars in series a funding
since its website launched in october do
you remember when we talked about this
first
yes it now has raised 40 million yeah
that's great do they have any stats in
there in terms of uh
more than 500 000 go back up more than
500 000 people signed up
for an account before launch that's cool
killer mike's got a killer platform and
he knows that
if he can pull people into uh that world
he can help them
right which i think is really really
smart and they're going specifically
after the black and latina
latinx which i think is latino latina
latinx
community and uh to me it just makes a
lot of sense
like you have to build for specific
demographics you have to build for
specific verticals
why do you think you have to build for
specifically a lot of it has to do with
the marketing right like
like the way that you speak to certain
groups if i sit down like i think one of
the skills that i have is if i sit down
with somebody on wall street i talked
about bitcoin in one way
when i go on andrew schultz podcast and
talk to him about it when you talk to my
dad you talking differently
of course so it's like you got to know
your audience right and so naturally
what that does is it provides
opportunity for people with different
marketing messages to have a very
similar product
i mean a deposit account's a deposit
account it's just how do you market it
and how do you position yourself in the
marketplace
all right delivery startup gopuff has
raised 1.15 billion dollars in funding
at an 8.9 billion dollar valuation wow
it's now available in more than 650 u.s
cities
rafael that's awesome what up
go puff had him on the podcast
absolutely
banger these guys get it they literally
try to get you
whatever you need delivery in like less
than 15 minutes or something what
it's just like you literally you press a
button and
that's right this is a soft bank backed
it is there
fast and so uh they've been growing very
quickly
they have these like outposts that was
what was so interesting to me
is basically they go into cities and
they have like almost like little
convenience stores
uh but they're not consumer-facing you
can't walk in and buy stuff
it's more like they get like a warehouse
like amazon warehouse style but they're
uh spread throughout a city and so they
can very quickly just get you whatever
you need
immediately uh because it's you know
down the street and somebody brings it
to you um
and by the way in miami we've been
seeing those little rovering like robots
that deliver things
all over it's so cool
if they come up to maybe barking at them
like a dog oh my god do you want to tell
them about the dog incident a dog i was
walking and a dog
yapped at me like started like barking
at me
and they did it when i got close and so
i just had a natural reaction
no i did not aggressively go towards it
all i did was i
looked at and i said what i say he said
calm down
calm down dog and the owner just looked
at me and i was like your dog barked at
me first
dog yelling they're walking away and i
said anthony you can't
yell at other people's dogs and he tried
to tell me that the dog started it and
the dog yelled at him first
it did facts i was walking peacefully
and the dog was there and then the dogs
kind of jumped at me and started barking
all crazy gotta put dog in its place
they'll be yelling at me or i'll yell
back
i'm a pacifist but like if you started
imma end it that dog got real quiet and
real
okay finally japan held a ceremonial
kickoff for the summer olympic games by
starting a relay of the olympic torch
around the country it was a symbolic
message that the games are going ahead
despite public skepticism and pandemic
restrictions that will block
overseas spectators from attending wait
so
the torch will be carried through all of
japan's 47 prefectures or states
by about 10 000 runners skiers swimmers
and others
before being brought into the olympic
stadium in tokyo on july 23rd
for the opening ceremony i love
the 10 000 people are gonna help bring
this torch you know how many people
like a thousand people is a lot and
there's ten times more
where do you find ten thousand people
well they're all the athletes and stuff
yeah but i don't think they're existing
athletes i don't know
yeah i'm not sure but 10 000 people is a
lot of people
to be handing torches like whatever like
what are we going to do just like
getting online and just pass it from
person to person
um they always do that i think it's a
tradition also um
cool well so so people from they're
gonna start it near fukushima wait
wait so people from all over the world
can't go to watch the olympic games
i don't think so are they gonna be
virtual no i think that they're not
allowing
audience right um i think that's true i
mean correct look you have the source
data don't be getting me to say fake
news here
i don't know i don't it doesn't say
yeah i'm pretty sure
right here the games are going ahead
despite public skepticism and pandemic
restrictions
so if you're in japan you can go but if
you're from outside japan then you can't
go
wow all right next all right it's ask
lunch money time
ask lm in the comments below we got one
from
savino longo i am a new dad and would
like to start an investment fund from my
child to hand over to her when she
graduates from high school
palm you have me convinced keeping it
keeping it in the bank is not the best
option
and i know of the 529 fund but what are
my crypto or even non-crypto options
that will help the money grow the most
thanks for taking my question this is
not financial advice
yeah look i think it's less about the
exact execution of this there's plenty
of financial advisors or people who who
do this for a living organic better
kind of execution advice my thing is
just when you start to do this from a
long time horizon
uh you can basically um be very very
patient and so
if you think about you know hey if i
contribute 20 bucks
every month and uh i do that for 15
years
and then it compounds at you know eight
ten percent
it's going to be a large sum of money uh
but then what happens if instead of
doing 20 bucks you do 100 or 200 right
if you can if you can afford to do that
then on top of that what if i don't get
eight to ten percent what if instead you
know bitcoin over the last 12 years has
compounded at 200
um annual uh compound annual growth and
so it's like
you can't look at the past performance
as an indicator of future performance
but what you can do is say hey if i take
a really really
long time horizon on something uh
where's the best place to put it
i think that you can figure out some
asymmetric type opportunities
and then you've got to figure out the
right vehicle right and there's all
kinds of tax implications whatever so i
don't want to
speculate because i don't know your
situation but that's how i would think
about it is just
use the time to your advantage don't
simply go and
and try to like day trade or do anything
crazy all right
moist counter today is day 30. um
if i had 6 billion dollars i would put 4
billion into bitcoin right away
i would use the other 2 billion to first
retire my parents then buy a bunch of
land for both personal use and to
generate passive income
i would also build a nice wrestling
facility for my old high school team
and perhaps perhaps other wrestling
programs around the country as well
with that much money i would also be
financially ready to take care of a
family
so i would start a wife hunt the
difficulty of that might be increased
though because i have to make sure that
the woman likes me
and not my six billion well technically
you only have two well i guess you have
six okay
by the way moist also use hashtag stop
censoring me youtube today
just so everyone knows in case anyone i
used to i
they're trying to keep us from each
other but it's all right i'm always it's
fine uh listen voice is very intelligent
i can already tell six billion dollars
that's no joke
uh and if you need two billion dollars
to retire your parents buy
land and to use it for personal use uh
we got questions i don't know what
you're doing but uh that's a lot of
money
four billion dollars in bitcoin pretty
smart uh and then you know being
financially ready to take care of a
family
uh is a very aspirational thing
um i don't know if you're allowed to say
wife hunt
though i feel like in today's day and
age that might be uh politically
incorrect to talk about it as a
hunting for a wife maybe it's a search
that might be a better uh use
better vernacular to use but i get you
you know we we're
we're basically the same person it
sounds like so i hear what you're saying
what do you think about his use of
proceeds
um i like i like the wrestling
thing i like if that's your passion you
want to help kids all over the country
um i like the retiring of the parents i
i think that's i think that's very good
um okay hold on do i have a hashtag keep
stanford wrestling
shout out joe pomp wait what they're
trying to kill the stanford wrestling
program
okay well if they're losing voices
coming in hot yeah boys got six billion
dollars
all right all right so i have a question
okay what's your question
okay post-pandemic what is
are we post-pandemic already no after
the pandemic is done
well never mind what is a country or a
place
i guess it has to be within a country
that you would
absolutely love to visit what is at the
top of your list
don't mess this one up what if he just
says home
mine is home what do you have to go
somewhere else what if he says miami
i don't know all right so you can say a
city or country
country place planet oh
no you have to be able to get there you
can go to other planets
they sent a mars rover okay it's only a
robot
moist is not a robot as far as i know
okay
all right guys that's it for lunch
winning today see ya bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block life's my second favorite thing in
the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments and we'll
see you guys tomorrow
and be kind to your friends